experience has been I mean it's electric
especially in the room where we just
were and where we showed the teaser it
was beyond anything we ever imagined
well a lot of people had said you're not
gonna believe the love in the room and
the power in the room and I was like oh
that's sounds sweet that's nice
standing out there on that stage was
extraordinary and when we showed the
teaser I've never heard a reaction like
that anything and it was it was really
the fans just having this this amazing
moment that we're so grateful for
because they care so much and it feels
so nice to get to share that with them
because you work on these things in Iran
for one thing is we think all the time
are we getting this right are we hitting
the right notes and when you get a
reaction like that
it's it's unbelievably gratifying now we
have a long way to go because we've got
seven months until we're actually faced
with the movie but this was this was
incredible
is it eight months I just want to like
I'm sure totally have December
no no but every minute we can get okay
okay focus
well I think we've reached a point now
where we can share something like this
with 23 countries and you know
unfortunately you want to have them all
in the room with you at the same time
but to be able to get a sense of how
this is playing and we've been actually
looking at some of the fan reactions
it's it's been really really incredible
to realize that we can connect people in
that way and Star Wars does that on a
level that almost nothing else does the
panel here at Star Wars Celebration
consisted of Kathy and myself and then
we got to bring out two of the amazing
droid builders Lee and Oliver who showed
their amazing work and then got to bring
out some of the cast Oscar Isaac John
boyega Daisy Ridley and that was really
fun and getting especially for Daisy
who's never done any sort of press
before and all to walk out into a room
like that sort of trial by fire and she
killed it and and then we got to bring
out some of the fan favorites Mark
Hamill Carrie Fisher Peter Mayhew
Anthony Daniels and that was a it was an
incredible thing to get to get together
again like that especially in front of
the fans yes we debuted the teaser so
that is yes second teaser it is probably
one of the more nerve-wracking things we
have to do because we put something out
that begins to represent the movie we're
making and we don't know exactly what
the reaction is going to be I would say
no the reaction was great but the nerves
were also and so it's a it's a huge
relief to get to show it and see that
they like the escalation of screaming
and then when Harrison says
we're home I'm in the place just went
absolutely insane it was bonkers yeah
yeah the force awakens is doing is using
the history that we all know from Star
Wars to tell a brand-new story
and so it's you know the history of the
characters in this world share the
history that we all know so that the
story is incorporating some brand new
heroes brand new characters to get
behind but also their relationships with
as the adventure continues with
characters that we already know and it's
been a wonderful thing seeing how much
everyone brings to the table and it's
it's like watching scenes between the
characters both all the new and and
combining them has been an extraordinary
thing to work
you